[Music]
I'm just waiting to see if he's gonna do
it I had it at two to one that you're
gonna start freestyling well eh I was
just waiting for the invite but listen I
appreciate the beat when it drops off
the top of the dome this real hip-hop
Navy representing the West Coast chillin
on the podcast my man left toe huh he's
going yeah your boys flowing I'm gonna
do my thing I'm gonna keep showing my
ass I'm a passer than anybody keep
tripping and that's Nate Burleson we
start tipping now listen my guy I've
been waiting for it to have you in
person for a long time you are an energy
person and I like we talked on the phone
recently yeah dude your [ __ ] Jew
story man I'm gas bro I was on my roof
today of my apartment and I literally
played the intro music just because I
knew you were gonna freestyle and I
visualized it yeah I wanted it to [ __ ]
well now I appreciate it I thought you
had some intro plan so I didn't want to
step on your feet no I'm just glad you
had a beat cuz me and Mike Rob used to
have the arm be podcast and I would
freestyle all the time all the time so
listen I'm glad that you gave me the
opportunity Oh will do again later if
you want but I am juice to be here
though because you know how social media
can be this thing that you see people
through this window and you can't feel
their energy but when I text you are
look at what you're doing it's not
always on social media sometimes I see
you on the biggest of all screens hey
watching you do your job I can feel that
energy bro so like being in person it's
like that times 10 right now welcome to
the speakeasy podcast Burleson you
you've had a few pocket when was that
the Micra podcast well the whoa RB was I
think about four or five years ago when
I was working in LA doing the speakeasy
was before that was before that I was
doing a little thing with cliff Abram we
were trying to do this speakeasy podcast
cuz I wanted to go to all the
speakeasies where players played but
that's when I was still in the West
Coast and I wasn't working five days a
week in morning TV work
get a lot into your path I think it's
been very interesting I did a deep dive
on a lot of stuff about you I want to
hear about your journey okay I want to
do a lot of conversations that are not
you talking about football that's great
but can I do a little bit in the
beginning no it's great we can talk
about some football okay cuz I want to
do a little bit in the beginning and
then I want to get into life
everything's on the table okay the first
thing that we need to talk about is a
trend that's been going on and the goat
has spoken the trend has been
quarterbacks in the NFL chugging beer
we've seen try Biscay we've seen mahomes
we've seen all of these guys go and the
one person that got embarrassed was
Aaron Rodgers right and Aaron Rodgers
yesterday came out and dropped an
absolute fireball spoken Aaron Rodgers
get him a scotch but also it's the truth
he's the greatest of all time I know I
stand by that but yeah well if you've
been enjoying this trend I have been and
you know what Aaron Aaron Rodgers was
holding the Ale for a while for a while
but I thought he was faking it
yeah I thought it was a whole like he's
methodical it's all strategic he sips is
slow he does just saying he kind of has
that very dry sense of humor so he was
laughing inside knowing the cameras on
them in the trend that's going around
basically like all of these other guys
are try hards I'm not a try-hard right
but all of a sudden he's Ron Burgundy
he's mr. scotch I love it yeah
kela guy what are you are you saying
he's um I'm at akela guy if I want to
turn up I'm going straight to the Keeley
yes and while you were setting this up I
thought you were gonna have some beer
and we was gonna check it but you know
we can do it at a different time
yeah go yeah but I don't want to get
into that right now okay so I rang
Malone I ranked the quarterbacks in
terms of beer-chugging
okay I had Big Ben at number one I had
Brady at number four I had like Baker at
number five last I had Kirk Cousins okay
I just felt like he'd be a guy that's
like chug we must enjoy things slowly
they pass over time and so what I
realized is it blew up people were
arguing how is carson wentz 20 he grew
up in North Dakota they are why do you
have Jimmy Garoppolo here we love
ranking the quarterback yes so I've
decided that I'm gonna do a new list
each week okay and I kind of want your
initial thoughts on what my list will be
this week it's going to be who would win
in NFL quarterback Hunger Games No so as
I say that to you
you're not gonna impact my list I'm
going to put it out on social media the
next like Thursday or Friday yeah what
comes to your mind right away
now Hunger Games you're talking just
like hunt to the death it's yes like
ice-t movie like the what's that movie
nobody was getting hunted by rich deer
hunter okay okay all right
well then right out the gate because you
need to be resourceful but you also need
to be super athletic right and you also
need to have that killer instinct I'm
gonna go with Cam right out the gate
okay
just cuz he's big he's strong he's like
the quarterback version of the predator
you know what about cam is also a
benefit
he's vegan which means if he's out there
in nature he can live off berries wholly
off the land yep so you're seeing what
I'm saying I'm going with Cam right out
the gate you know in the back of my mind
I'm telling myself go Russell Wilson go
Russell Wilson go Russell Wilson but I'm
not sure if he has that vicious side I'm
talking about agreed you know the blood
spills out of the corpse and he puts it
under his eyes like I black I'm not sure
if he has that don't let that psychopath
but he's changed this season he's gone
from Russell Wilson to Russell Wilson oh
he's like he's like stefan urquelle
after the yes machine exactly okay lay
into the bed with the with the chains
don't go to sleep hate a deal just got
down getting cornrows you know what I
mean like about it like look I had
Martellus Bennett on here and I played
it for him and he was stunned he's like
I've never seen this before he was like
I am a noted hater of Russell music I go
well this is Russell Wilson the other
things that come to my mind and as a dad
I believe that I automatically I'm gonna
move all quarterbacks that are dad's
higher because I believe they have an
Nate survival skill no doubt that
something's triggered in your brain that
hasn't triggered in my like I won't die
like Philip Rivers has seen some [ __ ]
yeah no no no no and with all those what
it's like to have an army of people
running at him yeah it's one thing to
like have one or two kids to live for
like after that eighth bullet he's like
I'm not gonna die I got my tenth kid on
the way yes he's gonna keep keep
fighting yeah you know I feel you on
that okay so you got those guys radius
up there again breeze breeze I think is
one of those guys that's gonna be going
to be that one of the best tactician
he'll know his strengths and weaknesses
and he won't go into open spaces Kyler
Murray is gonna be overconfident yeah
I'm the fastest guy here yeah you know
cuz hyung might get clipped off early
but I don't know about Brady Brady's the
goat in every realm of life you know the
wife the job the business is of course
football the rings the championships but
he's a big target and he's slow true now
he's a cheat as a big point is IQ is
through the roof but speed is a big part
of those huh I mean you can't hide out
forever right you know it's kind of like
fortnight eventually that that that
circle is gonna close and you gotta you
got to stay within the storm radius Kirk
Cousins is gonna be higher for me
because I only I know that he doesn't
have the killer instinct but he may have
been a boy scout and thus you might know
how to start fires like seems like I got
you know who's gonna be a meeting room
resourceful Kirk Cousins you know who
might be my number one who Andrew Luck
likes the part he's just sitting there
like you turn a corner and he has an
entire tree house made yeah but I don't
know if he has the killer instinct all
right I gotta think about it list will
be coming out soon yeah Andrew Luck
looks like he ki what about Carson Wentz
though North Dakota North Dakota he's a
hottie as a hunter I mean he can wear
that camouflage blend in with anything I
bet you and he you know he's he's a
businessman so I feel like it's kind of
like avatar after he kills his opponent
he prays he's like thank you for
providing he doesn't proper burial yeah
yeah which as we've seen Hunger Games
the smoke might go so that's one of my
NFL top excitement I won't get involved
and though they're serious and if I'll
talk with you okay when Calvin Johnson
retired yeah the Detroit Lions made him
give back I believe a million dollars
worth of his salary yep right on it's
the second time in the his
the Detroit Lions were one of their
greatest performers was forced to give
back money Barry Sanders retired after
nine years had to give back salary
Calvin Johnson retired after nine years
had to give back salary and now the
Lions come out and go we'd love to have
Calvin as a spokesperson to the teeth
Calvin responds and I'd like to get my
money yeah one what the hell were the
Lions thinking and two what would you
tell Calvin Johnson right now well one
I'm not gonna tell how much Johnson
anything I agree with them 100% you guys
know I'm aligned through and through but
I saw this coming the writing was on the
wall
it's funny how history repeats itself
how do you approach a player Barry
Sanders Calvin Johnson that gave you so
much and not just in the moment let's
just think about the impact they have on
this organization when it comes to
selling their likeness the images the
videos the jerseys the hope Stafford
help him recruit players yes like all of
these different things come into play so
that million dollars that chump change
bro pales in comparison to what Calvin
is still bringing in to this team from a
revenue standpoint I remember when
Calvin Johnson was thinking about
retirement and I was removed from the
Giant I mean from the Lions at that
point and I gave him a call and I'm like
what's up fam how you doing I was in
Arizona it was sunny as hell and I
remember looking into the Sun squinting
my eyes and I'm like yo CJ so what's up
what you gonna do and he's like I don't
know man you know as soon as I brought
up the thought of retirement there were
rumors within the organization that I
would have to pay back money Wow and
just by the tone of his voice I knew
that he was done he didn't tell me he
didn't confirm him and say I'm done I'm
walking away from the game but when I
hung up I thought to myself it's a wrap
Calvin won't play for the Lions again
we've talked about those before with an
athlete contemplates retirement yeah
he's pretty much already pretty much
retired it it's one thing for me to
contemplate it because you know I got a
lot going on and I'm thinking but that's
the next chapter or I'm at the end of my
my playing days but the fact that
somebody else makes you think about it
for issues that our financial base like
that's the ultimate slap
in the face disappointment sadness anger
like what was I think it was I think it
was first anger and Calvin's a machine
he's kind of like Kauai Lenore he
doesn't show his emotions but it has to
be some sadness because Calvin was this
dude he would show up every single year
never complain never talked about being
traded even though every team wanted
them never mentioned the money even
though the team was going to pay him he
was never a diva he never showed up and
said you know I need your quarterback to
get the ball down on me I'd over five
straight balls and my body's beat up my
shoulder hurts like this one they come
and quadruple covered and I'm still
doing what I'm throwing the medicine
balls in the air and I'm sitting there
saving the offense every third down he
never said that he would come to
practices and not have a small limp that
would go away after his body warms up he
would have a significant limp yeah by
the end he was really beaten up there
were times I practiced where and this
isn't making a joke to anybody this
disabled but you ever see somebody in
the gym you could tell they had like a
really bad injury at some point in their
life and there's this really bad limp
maybe that stiffness or a short leg or
whatever it is a hip injury right Calvin
would limp through practice like that
sometimes to the point one practice a CJ
what you doing bro now I'm just trying
to get through man you know being a
leader I got it I gonna show that I'm
ready for this game this week I sit and
CJ it's Wednesday fam later you're good
exactly they want me out there and that
was the thing they wanted all their
starters out there so the starters can
get a feel for the game plan I walked
over to Scott Linehan and I said CJ's
done like he's done for the day
he needs to be in the training room if
we want a chance like just a fighting
chance to win the game we need our best
player healthy I will do double time I
run my routes and then when he has his
place where he's getting the ball I'll
run his routes I'm good and he said ha
man I didn't know is that bad he went
and talked to coach and I said season I
walked overseas I said bro I'm working
it out with you just walk off the field
yeah he walked off and that was one of
the moments where I think I realized
just how much he was going through yeah
physically and also mentally sure that
he was
he was so locked in and so sacrificial
to his body for this organization and I
think he also realized you know how much
I care about him because like I could
care less about the touchdowns right
game day I wanted my man to be healthy
you're on the room together with all of
that I knew that he was done for even so
much so like even I was angry and it
spilled out I did an interview just
about the receivers the following season
this is actually retired and I said you
know by the way if I was making this
list and Calvin Johnson was still
playing he'd be number one he's that
good even though he's banged up last
year and then I said let me say
something to Kelvin while I'm doing this
and I think it was a piece that we ran
it on the NFL Network I said I come out
of retirement and play for the Patriots
and go win a ring and people got so mad
at me Michigan people write Detroit
Lions fans they got mad at me how could
you say that it's ridiculous like you're
one of the ones that we trusted I can't
believe that you would even insinuate
yeah that that would be a possibility
but they didn't know that I knew the
backstory of course of what Calvin was
dealing with and it was me you know
speaking on my frustration with the
organization that didn't understand the
grand scheme of things like that's when
somebody's thinking about the dollars
and cents but it don't make sense
you literally gave a speech about
Detroit at the NFL Draft that was so
moving that it is plastered on the walls
in the Detroit Lions organization yeah
so what should the Lions do to make this
better because you care about the Lions
and you care about Calvin Johnson yeah
and they're at an impasse yeah what
should they do I feel like it should be
it should be one of those cases that you
hear about but when it's all said and
done it goes away and we just hear that
a settlement was made in closed-door
closed-door take care of them because in
the NFL world this is a hot case and
we're all waiting to hear what the Lions
are gonna say and if Calvin Johnson is
gonna you know work his way back here's
the thing about money sometimes money
will turn people off to the point they
can't turn their feelings back on so the
fact that Calvin Johnson saying you know
what you need to do now that almost
makes the Lions feel good in this
situation like a come out here to this
facility let's
talk here's some money and we'll be good
cuz you need him as an ambassador yeah
the same thing had happened to Barry
Barry for a long time walked away from
the game of football couldn't handle it
he just wasn't around bro like and for
him not to be there like I remember him
walking to the facility and it was like
Prince walking in it was like damn is
that Barry Sanders I was an NFL PA Super
Bowl party in San Francisco for Super
Bowl 50
and all these NFL players are there and
everybody's drinking and having a good
time and Barry was the man Barry he had
a nice little potbelly at the time he
was very much in retirement older guy
but when I saw him shaking hands with
these young players they glow yeah
because nobody has a better highlight
package than Obata Sanders nobody well I
wanted to get fixed my take has always
been the Detroit Lions did Calvin
Johnson wrong I think it's a very easy
fix which is I would give him two
million dollars
yeah I'd say here's an extra million for
inconveniencing you now and it was not
for it was there was no foresight there
no no you need to write that wrong no
doubt for the fans for him and also like
just see the bigger picture the bigger
picture like you're an NFL organization
you got and that's it the bigger picture
now he comes back you give him two
million dollars not only he's an
ambassador but maybe he comes back more
often he's part of the organization he's
in the front office like he's you know
she to the wide receiver room he's in
Michigan a ton he has a lot of business
going on out there yeah and he does
things with the communities like how is
he there talking to kids yeah but not
talking to the team that's the Lions
fault another wide receiver and this is
gonna be my last NFL news nugget before
we get into you it's all good is I am
having an issue with I've always had an
issue with the way Odell Beckham jr. is
covered okay but I'm having an issue
right now with covering Odell Beckham I
will never get angry at a star player
not showing up in May the Patriots won
the Super Bowl Brady wasn't there in May
right the year before the Eagles won the
Super Bowl
Fletcher Cox wasn't there in May yeah
Super Bowls are not won in May I
remember playing in Seattle and Walter
Jones Oh
Michelle showed up and came embodied
doozy
like body them guys that are super elite
it's not that they don't need it they
have their own system no doubt Odell has
trainers with them
Odell has the PlayBook he's doing all
this I always have an issue with Odell
my thing is this though I don't worry
about fans eventually in Cleveland
getting upset with Odell it's bound to
happen something's gonna happen I'm
looking at the relationship of Baker and
Jarvis and Odell and that's where I
think he can get tricky yeah
working with family and friends is a
scary thing no don't because the job can
carry over to your personal life Baker
Mayfield just came out and called out
Duke Johnson saying I love Baker I love
him to death I did I said I didn't like
that okay I didn't like that I had a
take today on the show and I think the
reason these young guys respect me is
because I'll praise him like crazy right
I'm part of the fraternity but when I
have to say something I'm bold enough to
say it and then see an off season and be
like how did you feel about what I said
the reason I like is because he said
it's not awkward it's not awkward at all
and then the reporter why why isn't it
awkward Duke Johnson has a situation he
wants to be traded he was on the blocks
before he said no it's all
self-inflicted he doesn't wanna be
doesn't wanna be here you know Baker
goes into the hole if you're not on the
ship then you're you're getting ran over
come on you said about Hugh Jackson say
anything and a part of me want to listen
to the sound it's like damn it
I love Baker for that like that's right
I get all excited because me they're
with us you again yes I love that
because a lot of guys you do for the
check
yeah who's literally doing it for the
logo still at that College feeling still
yeah but then again I like Baker what if
next year it's Jarvis oral deal or what
if five years from now it's you and
you're saying man I'm one of the best
quarterbacks in league and they're not
paying me like Russell Wilson and I'm
better I'm younger I got more numbers
look at what I did over the first five
years it always happens right every
quarterback has been a situation and if
a teammate came out was like yo man
you're doing too much just just take the
money you got you signed it you saw
self-inflicted like it's not awkward
awkward for you you're the quarterback
take the money like now the roles have
reversed because here's the thing and it
always gets reverse it always gets
reverse no it will happen there's no
situation where Baker Mayfield is gonna
get the first off
the team says he's like yeah sure I'll
take it right he's going to be in the
same situations Duke Johnson different
type of money different situations but
I'm just saying be careful because this
could happen to you that's what I said
today only I'm gonna happen to Odelle
like a year or two Adele's gonna want
another contract and then what's Baker
gonna say then but my thing is I love
that Freddie kitchens last week comes
out and says Odell's missed a lot the
offense and then yesterday after the
first practice he goes man Hodel picked
up the offense really well come on bro
yeah but it's the way in which we talk
about Odell and I'm gonna I'm gonna
share something that I am openly rooting
for Odell always mhm I'm seeing people
talk about Odell the way they talked
about young Iverson which is it's not
attacking him the people that he hangs
around with a circle now he's Odell
[ __ ] Beckham in my mind other than
Tom Brady's the most famous player in
the LEAs of rock star fam he can go into
Lewis Hamilton's booth at in Monaco and
watch an f1 race and he's more famous
than the racer no doubt but and I want
like he's 20 whatever years old I want
him to experience these things in life
and I don't know if I'm worried about
the people that he's around if that's
just this media creation but I know that
I'm frustrated with the media and I know
I'm frustrated with the fans because you
really think Odell's not given a [ __ ]
he's the most competitive dude you know
him really well I don't I'm just curious
about your notion of how we talk about
Odell you know it's funny because I
spoke on on deal when I first started
covering him from a fan's perspective
and then I ended up exchanging
information with his mom and we kept in
contact Shore and then I ended up doing
his camp which was the first time we
really got to hang out with each other
aside from seen each other on we're car
so it's kind of on your knee like when
you're on the ground together talking
right yeah right so but then recently
something happened over the last year
where we actually exchanged information
and for a while like I knew his mom
never asked for anything I never hit his
mom like you I need the school and I
think she respected that sure they'll
respected that
but more recently we've had these
conversations about life about football
and he is a very very passionate do and
I wouldn't trade that in for anything
and when he talks about how he's
perceived it messes with them and all
could it not and it you know it's the
thing like we assume that football
players are just rock stars and they
deal with it and it comes with the
territory right look at your mention
it's what you sign up for fam when you
do care you can't just kick it's like a
light switch like it's either on or off
there's no dimmer with superstar so oh
they'll can't just say oh mama just care
about football and not care about how
the fans perceive football and how the
fans perceived the athlete and how the
fans talk about the athlete and it's
just one big revolving circle and I told
them a long time ago I said then you
have to understand the reason they're
attacking you like this and they want
you to falter within this storm of
criticisms is because not that they're
stopping you from being successful in
the field that's gonna come and go
they're trying to stop you from building
an empire like you're you're the next
step like its sneaker deals its
production its TV and movies if you want
it it's the music space it's art pop
culture social media it's all these
different things he has true crossover
appeal it's not I haven't seen a lot of
NFL players that do let's keep it real
how about after he's got American NFL
players that can cross over to every
race Shore every genre somebody from
Nashville I lost country music be like
that damn old Dale's pretty damn good
yeah and somebody from the hood a sense
this would be like a bro my [ __ ] old
Dale is the truth like it crosses over
from everywhere and now here it's like
yo son
your daddy's mad nice be like you know
like it's every guy every place just
forget about it when it comes to the
women like they they love him so when it
comes to that I think Oh Dale has he's
understood over the last two years and I
said it on the show they love you then
they hate you and they love you again
they'll always come back around with
your true to form and this is what I
said about in New York and him getting
traded whatever like people trade play
and it's it's all up to the eye of the
beholder right but for me it was the
fact that they got rid of him and he
realized very quickly that even though
you're a rock star
you're still disposable so it puts
things in perspective and when I had a
conversation with a couple weeks ago
this is how real of a dude all jealous
he was supposed to travel to LA and
we're on the phone just talking about
life and random stuff and he's like I
might shoot out the Arizona I supposed
to be in Arizona I'm like well I'll be
an Arizona my best friend is celebrating
his 38th I'll be out there he was like
man I might I might shoot through that
still you type of money you got that's
private he was in I think he's a
Cleveland sighs like y'all be in LA
tomorrow I was like okay well being a Z
Friday he's like I might shoot through
he doesn't have sky priority yeah I'm
like okay all right whatever I told my
best friend I'm like yo Odell City my
slide please yeah right so we pull up we
at the house you know we chillin you pop
a couple bottles just all the fellas
sitting there watching TV trying to
figure out what we're gonna do that
night and sure enough I get a cause like
y'all brought us a dress I'm pulling up
Odell comes to Wow and even my boys who
are grown man summer kids fan boys fan
boys yeah even me I'm shocked and I know
him and I'm like yo what's up and I'm
keeping it cool like that but so bright
he doing he's all y'all we said well my
staying in man like fellas that's
awesome and he just kicked back in chill
and we went out and he didn't steal the
show
he wasn't like yo it's me he lay back in
the cut yeah and we walk in first
Odell walks in it's a whole different
ball I was able to see it from like his
perspectives kick game with him for the
first time see that like orange stick
over there yes signed by Odell it's when
we had him dress up like a security
guard at the Super Bowl
I don't nobody know was him yeah and
what was wild was for the first 15 20
minutes
Sims and I are watching him and he's
doing it he's like he's got a mask on
and no one knows and we're laughing and
then he pulled it down and like talked
to a kid and it was like watching
contagion like I'm watching a virus
spread outbreak and all of a sudden
everyone's looking and
it was or that Denzel movie where like
you fall somewhat fallen in like the
spirit awesome is Oh Massa and to watch
everyone and then to watch him be
comfortable navigate that pack and
realize I mean if we took like an aerial
shot it would just be like zombies yeah
wild to watch I mean I'll take it a step
further so we're out in Arizona I think
we're at some day spot just a lounge
eatin and chillin this girl comes up
frantic hey yeah okay I got a let me go
in and play bodyguard I'm gonna be a
filter but not an [ __ ] exist before I
step in and be that [ __ ]
Odell kind of like hits my hand down
like let me talk to him hmm FaceTime
he's on the phone with this young boy
right and he's talking to him the kids
going crazy mom takes the phone I run
into that same woman like two minutes
after they hang up the phone
tears like welling up like real tears
yeah and she's like I haven't seen my
son
cry tears of happiness like that that's
why I'm crying right now oh and then I
came back and I was like see Odell
that's what people don't know about you
like they don't know that side yeah they
see the headlines anyone with the
headlines they don't know that side even
so much so in the same trip my son who
just broke his ankle I'm like hey yo I'm
on the phone FaceTime and I'm sitting
next to him yeah and he leans over I was
like what's up he grabs the phone and my
son's eyes near my eyes light up and
he's sitting there with his boot on and
his crutches he's like man hey don't
worry about it man you gonna bounce back
you young you gonna how do you my son's
like 13 he's like man don't worry about
it man when I was 10 this happened and
he showed the same type of ankle break
in the same place and showed him the
score damn this dude was going way above
and beyond my other side it's like I got
the old Delicato Dylan injury we're just
gonna make actually went to Odell's
doctor um and then my older son same
thing and my wife was there and she's
just kind of like I get that old girls
hanging out with y'all but why is he
being so friendly the thing is he's not
being friendly he was just being all
Dale yeah and that right there
me it's something that I'll never forget
listen if Dale messes up he knows I'll
be critical of them if he does something
stupid on the field I'm gonna talk about
it and if I feel like I gotta say
something to him and call him I will
one thing I would never do though yeah
is act above it because listen I was a
decent superstar made decent money we
had this conversation I said bro what I
did in the millions I made and being
able to party and kick it and lose my
mind in the streets before the social
media era really took shape like you're
dealing with what I dealt with times a
million yes and you're handling it great
yeah I was like don't worry about it
these small mistakes they're gonna be
looked at especially as Giants fans and
I guarantee like a few years from now
that I'm blowing damn it wasn't that bad
it's like breaking up with a great
saying that I posted video of him at his
first practice and the mentions on the
left go show account I miss where Giants
fans going this is making me so [ __ ]
sad right now my thing about Odell that
frustrates me for the fan perspective is
they don't understand how media works
right when you go on your social media
feeds and it's videos of Odell dancing
he did not put it on your feet all of
these media companies from bleach report
to ESPN to NFL Network know that when
they put Odell on the feed it gets
numbers so so they're the ones choosing
to flood your feed with Odell know that
I think a lot of people get overwhelmed
with the amount of Odell coverage right
but it's not his fault
right it's the same thing with like
Justin Bieber like he's not being asked
to be mobbed on the street and and and
they're not realizing that if you have
an issue it's with media companies no
doubt it's with the teams that are
choosing to put that on their social
Adele would probably like to live a very
private life no doubt if he's dancing at
a pool party
it's not his fault when all the camera
phones come up no down and I just wish
fans could understand that it's a it's a
media driven narrative that the reason
you're overwhelmed it's not Odell asking
it's not at all and he doesn't want to
be the face of chaos everywhere he goes
it's enough to be the best receiver on
the field
he's playing he's like when I'm out
chilling like I just want to be private
I remember we were hanging out and we it
was Arizona so it was sunny outside it's
the middle of the day we went to a
little day club and we're chilling we
get a nice little table a nice little
booth and I had a band in a colorful
bandanas just wrapped around my waist up
around my belt band and and he took it
and put it over his head and then put
his head on because he realized the
blond hair and his face is gonna stand
down more than my boys birthday and I'm
like oh they'll like you could be all
Dale bro you can steal the show what
he's like no it's your boys birthday who
we just met yeah
my bestie people also need to realize
he's from New Orleans right like I am
very much a believer in your upbringing
is so different showmanship and people
that are from but also New Orleans is
also a very community-based humble space
you know there are showmanship but those
parades have a purpose no doubt you know
what I like it's not just no doubt like
the people that go to New Orleans
and get shit-faced and leave they're not
New Orlean to chaos yes yes yes but they
want to just sit there and kick back in
all that sold out thank you for that
perspective oh no dude yeah I have
believed for a long time that and you
can stop me I think you're you want to
talk about more than football so much
and I think you've been on this path for
a long time yeah I have found so many
articles of you doing crossover stuff
from you were on wheel of fortune in
2004 yeah like that's 14 15 years ago
now I'm finding articles from your agent
where you're talking about we're working
a lot a lot of deals right now don't
cross over stuff yeah I feel as though
not saying that football bores you yeah
but you're I feel like you're ready for
more yeah I definitely am you know I've
been doing this since I was eight you
know and now being removed from the game
since 2014 you know waking up and
talking about football every day I mean
it's exciting because the storylines
change but as you know it's the same
thing just repackaged it's the same
storylines different players in
different trips why do whoa big
offseason because every year there's a
third string tight end that might take
over the NFL
the same thing that's just saying
storylines that we hear there's always a
new quarterback getting paid and he's
supposed to be the next one up to save
his franchise and taken to the Superbowl
in that the storylines going forever so
for me I'm not gonna say I feel like the
walls are closing in but they're closing
in so what do you want to talk about
because I look at your page and I see
this I see inspiration yeah i sea lions
blood yeah I say what up doe yeah you
know I see I see
you're a businessman no doubt and you've
been I mean ever since way back in the
day
yeah working with brands on your page
but also it's a lot of like positive
reinforcement you're very into showing
familial love yeah fatherhood and stuff
so what what is you know your mission
statement what is that you want to talk
about the most when I first entered the
league I was 21 and I thought to myself
all right I'm gonna be different than
every other player I'm gonna own a
restaurant I'm gonna launch some
clothing lines I wanna be a entrepreneur
I'm even gonna rap under alias and I
started do all those things I got I
recorded a song with Macklemore when I
was playing with the CEO under the alias
New Balance and I used to like do poetry
and I and then I realize all right
nobody wants to hear all that stuff from
a football player so then when I got
done playing levy on bells realizing
yeah he got he got a lit up on social
media just spit some bars you ain't
gotta go soon if your player don't go
out of tune I agree just bit bar bleats
before my dream is to get cold easily
and levy on bail to go there in a cypher
Oh watch Cole go ahead Oh Co got bars
okay all right so anyway so yeah so I
quickly realized that nobody wanted to
see variety out of a full part they want
to see you play football and then when I
was writing yeah definitely definitely
and then when I retired I was like all
right I'm going to TV and I remember
when I first got an info network I was
like look all right here it is I want to
do like like animated cartoon SNL skits
you know I'm saying and then I also want
to do like spoking work and I also want
to rap because there's these like these
these hip-hop recaps that are fired I'm
saying and if we can do that in the
football space like we kill it every
year and then also when I produce my
show I also want to do like my own my
own nightly show which is like more than
sports I mean I have a live band I have
a co-host and we do celebrities and can
I guess what the response was go ahead
Tony that's that's good
we're gonna want you on our main news
program and we're gonna ask you about
your takes on other players yeah that's
the lane we'd like you to fasten yeah
and it was almost in more direct and
then it was like just just chill out bro
like just relax we're gonna actually
like how this post corner it was
effective and how old I'll make that
three and catch our two three finger
catch so for me I was like damn that's
deflating and then I thought alright
we'll approach it like your approach
football like I earned the respect by
working harder than everybody else and
show how versatile you are so I did and
then so many years later I did like
three rat recaps I did one for CBS two
for NFL Network I've recited poetry on
my show I did an animated series last
year where I told stories and that was
successful and I'm in talks right now of
creating an entertainment show that
might have a sports hook and quite
frankly this may be news to you know my
employers if it doesn't have a
entertainment hook then I'll go
elsewhere and find that because listen I
was born in the 80's raised in the 90s
influenced by the 2000s like it spills
out when I talk I see in your posts you
were more excited to interview Lady Gaga
oh my god than anything else
I saw last year for the Super Bowl you I
don't know if it was the Super Bowl you
interviewed Tracy Morgan yeah and I can
see in your caption and I can see in
your presence yeah that [ __ ] got you
super pumped listen that type of [ __ ]
right there makes me feel alive again
because as much as I want to make you
know talking about football new you
can't reinvent the wheel too much
because Anibal wanted how they've got
this yeah and and I have to respect the
traditionalists who tuned in and say
don't be too over-the-top like it's just
football be entertaining but don't you
go left on me because I'll turn the
channel and I want to keep people tuned
in and that's that's how I respect the
Masters who watch our shows but when I
get a confident feel network and they're
like eh oh we need somebody to interview
Lady Gaga and I'm like why are you
calling me well Frasier thank you so
weak and I'm like all right well steel I
don't understand they're like well
you're one of those guys that live in
the pop culture space like she's doing a
national anthem I think it'd be great
now you'd be like but
he got you'd be like and I'm there and
I'm there I'll bring my own water
exactly my own makeup and everything and
I remember doing that walking in after
preparing like crazy with some like real
subtle subtle like additions to the
questions that I knew she would
appreciate and I remember walking in and
it was like Charlie Murphy describing
prints like she floated across the room
smoke on the ground no bro I am NOT this
global came from behind I feel like I
can walk in any woman be like I'm a Leo
like I'm a true lion I talk about all
the time like put me anywhere it's my
jungle I'm gonna dominate a football
field that jungle I'll dominate the
concrete jungle New York I'll dominate
but she was like the first lioness that
was like just looked through my soul
like stole my spirit now I remember her
walking in she just walked from a
distance
never broke eye contact which for me I
feel like I can win that battle and she
never broke it not today and she was
like she sat down and I remember us
talking and I I would put her song
titles in the question so I think at
that point she realized damn just dude
he did his work yeah and there was a
moment where I knew she won and she had
me flustered like we were we paused the
interview we had like another 6 minutes
left and I'm trying to be cool and start
talking production talk a lot of it I
don't even really know of is if it's
real but I wanted to seem cool from the
production not just like I'm talking to
the producers in the team surrounding me
while she's sitting there and I thought
she would be on her phone talking to her
handlers she's I'm like alright so we're
gonna stop for a second then we'll be
right back we're gonna adjust my camera
since she's like she's looking at me
like this she's like ok so as she's
looking at me I'm like alright and so
then I'm like I be cool do something
cool and I'm like alright so uh Tommy
we're going to come around to the one
shot okay yep and we're gonna scooby-doo
to left and okay and then once we do
that the five minute rotational and then
after the backflip will come to you
wanted to show that you could control
just talking out of my ass as I'm
talking out of my ass about 45 to 50
seconds later I just I kind of like go
back to where I was to address her like
are you ready and she kept staring at me
the whole time and not like not like
staring like casually like she just
following my head
then when I came back she was looking I
never had anybody just like threw me in
the back of my knee start sweating
that's a touch you know my heart start
flowing I was like all right I guess
we're gonna get back excuse me I guess
when we get back to her all right let's
go three two and I had to have to
recalibrate and I remember thinking to
myself like damn how home was a gypsy
like she got it she got to us I don't
know she's up she might be all of them
she lucky she got the juice bro and she
walked away but to your point though
that made me feel alive it was so
different than what I was used to then I
just I felt I felt encouraged to one
adir more vet she's an Aries I don't
know do you know signs are you a sign
guy I'm a sign guy but I don't know
arias I don't have many of those in my
life what sign do you think I am I wish
I'm a Taurus
oh that would say bullheaded my best
friend's are tourists yeah
Tauruses and Leos get along yeah oh yeah
yeah cuz we're similar yeah we approach
things the same virgos are very
understanding and they're very calm yeah
yeah we're calm but to what you were
saying though about it's like expanding
yourself you've done that you know it
yeah but I think the thing when you're
an athlete I have a lot of friends that
have gone through retirement and I see
that struggle of identity yeah and for
me like I'm just a person on camera and
like yeah I have like kind of navigated
that too but like for a lot of people
when you're an athlete you're always an
athlete yeah and we're in a media space
where we all want to make great work
yeah we all want to do perennial
sensitive man but but it's also so
surface-level yeah and sometimes less is
expected out of a former athlete and I
could imagine that's frustrating because
you want more
it really is it's it's um it's my
version of today's music like you'll see
a young artist and they'll just flood us
with music they're just dropping song
after song and album after album because
they're obligated or contractually
obligated by the streaming platforms are
their record label but then when you
really break it down it's like alright
what has little little gotti given me
over the last three years that that has
native with my soul no disrespect little
yachty plane is powerful
you got a great following but there's a
there's a group of young guard asset
they're not doing like heavily impactful
stuff which a lot of them say i don't
want to that's not my thing and
sometimes you'll get in this business
they know that age four they understand
no but then you know sometimes people
there in this business and they're like
I'm gonna just flood the media space
which is a lot of content yes and that's
how I'm gonna win and that's a good
strategy
I don't want to do a lot of content no
because I feel like at some point people
are gonna just drown out your voice and
didn't to be honest that's my fear when
being in the football space forever if
I'm doing this for twenty years twenty
years from now with you know salt and
pepper on my beer
and me talking about man back in 2010 it
was crazy man like people will be like
oh may you still talking about Randy
Moss over like I wrote down I was like
I'm not asking you a single [ __ ]
question my writing you can't it's fun
there's no no no no no because for me
like you talked about how you put Lady
Gaga's lyrics into their questions I
thought another one of your posts
where after you interviewed Omari
Hardwick you felt the need to show McCoy
was it a question that you weren't able
to ask like was there not enough time it
was but it was one that you really put a
lot of thought into and crafted I took
all of his movie titles and I crafted
one big long that's why he reacted like
that yeah which is really funny because
part of the reason I went from a local
reporter to a national is i weaved in
rap rap lyrics Seinfeld stuff and
wrestling things on three different news
cast into the newscast you just make it
a mad lib yeah because you can
understand the construct of a sentence
and where you can put those things
exactly but I saw what you were doing
with Omari was it you're a performer
yeah whether it's athletics or on camera
on the same way we're but you want that
notion of I see what you see yeah and we
can see it through the same lens yeah
and you said I want you to be my mentor
like yeah I don't even think you just
doing an entertainment show is it like I
don't even a lot of people say you
should know what your goals are right
people that say that haven't reached
goals like you're gonna reach a goal
then you're gonna go what now what next
like I don't even think you know what
you're gonna do no I don't I don't it
was funny you know when I talked to
Amari afterwards and we were sitting
here going back and forth and when he's
walking away he was like you're gonna be
an actor and I you know you sound like
my mom my mom was it being a movie he's
like now you're avoiding it eventually
you're gonna be an actor what you do
your poetic and you work well with the
camera and you want to challenge
yourself and that's the most challenging
thing you can do is it I believe I
believe so for me because as much as I
was a performer on the field there's a
certain sense of performance anxiety I
would always get always before every
game because I knew there was an art
form behind a layer behind the X's and
O's and I wanted to give people both I
wanted to be the best player I could be
for my team but I wanted people to walk
away remembering the game stylistically
I enjoyed watching and that's it so but
you're right though I don't know exactly
what it ought to be but I don't get
intimidated by that no no no I I want to
do it all man and then here and you know
jay-z hit the billion mark it's like do
I want to be a mogul like I'm having
these meetings where I'm sitting down
with multi millionaires and some of the
smartest people in the world I'm like
maybe I should just dive into this
business space and I give that all I got
but then I listen I got caught up when I
moved in New York and I know you're
familiar with this being a West Coast
guy and not knowing what this East Coast
like really like hamsterwheel is like
trying to take over the world every day
I woke up yeah and I remember like
immediately I had like three jobs and
number-one thing my fiance tries to like
calm me down Jack you don't need to work
all the time I remember waking up in
like these heyguys gaps in my beard and
I'm like don't shave which is weird so
then I went to a dermatologist she's
like oh that's alopecia and I'm like you
know she's like you have history oh they
know she's gay you're you have alopecia
you have big baby baby bootie clean
spots on your beard they look like crop
circles so I couldn't grow a full beard
and I thought to myself well I don't
know why this is happening and she said
you're stressed and I was like I'm not
stressed she's like what are you doing
different I'm I uh I wake up at 4:00 in
the morning
to wake up a seven play football and she
didn't know I played football so she
glossed over that and then she said well
you're stressed out because of your new
job and you you probably want to be
really good and it turned into this
therapy session a dermatologist and I
said no no how lady I don't think you
get it I was a football player so there
was like dudes they were like 275 yes
that would like literally try to fall so
why I'm gonna be stressed with a camera
you can feel me so I'm go back for PCs
life was on the line yeah she's like not
but you loved football it's different
like this love is new so you know and I
started looking at things theatrically
because that's how I look at it it's
this new woman that I'm in love with cuz
football that love affair was over she
broke up with me she's like you say that
and then and and I think this new woman
I was so held not it wasn't the job of
working the morning show it was this
woman of New York like she was she was a
lot to keep up with and after I like
kind of like figured out where to put my
energy and not work so much and Willie
to be honest just keep myself at the
crib that's my like my beer start
brewing it like a year later so funny
and it's crazy I had to start turning
down jobs and saying no to like make
myself help all the over quantity that's
exactly what we're talking what is your
what time do you wake up right now
4 a.m. first alarm goes off and then you
go you live in Jersey I live in Jersey
it's a 45-minute commute
so I usually hop in a car around 4:45
and then you get to the studios just to
do 5:30 meeting and then we're live at
7:00 I'm done at 10:00 and then we have
a post-show
meeting I'm going over the next day show
and then from there I hop in the car and
I'm headed back home then my son is
training and I go pick up my daughter at
3:00 and then from there it's basketball
or tennis or you know dance flip your
sleep schedule in the weekends or do you
just go I'm gonna wake up at 4 a.m. on
Saturday and it's not I flip it I sleep
in as much as I can I try to and I used
to be that dude I think while I was
stressed also my buddy like adjusted
crazy you know some people say hey man
take you like a mutton hat two months
tops it took me like two years to get
used to waking up at 4:00 a.m. and now I
just sleeping on the weekends but I used
to like fight my sleep and another thing
I broke my nose when I was playing so I
was breathing like out of my 100%
capability I was
like 20% didn't realize it Wow so I went
through the nose doctor he's like yeah
when you broke your nose and playing for
the Vikings when you were at the
hospital how did they fix I was like
Hospital they fix it on a sideline he's
like what yeah they took put a stick in
there and they that's exactly what they
did
and he said Oh for that reason your your
right nostril has been slowly collapsing
over time so when you have allergies or
you have a cold or it gets really humid
in your house multiply by 100 you can't
breathe sleep like I was struggling
broke up when I say struggling I was we
gonna before no morning I was probably
sleeping like 2 hours tops this was not
this was not your throat polyps this is
not my throat polyps that was that was
before this like I saw this stuff after
I got done playing see you at one point
had polyps are cancerous
yakked yeah in your throat and were not
like able to talk for a little bit I
wasn't about that so someone that loves
to talk and tell stories has made a
career there was a part of your life
where that was maybe threatened yeah no
doubt in that's a mindfuck no doubt
listen I was watching the movie a
thousand words the other day with Eddie
Murphy and it's a movie about a tree
having a thousand leaves and he only has
a thousand words left before they in the
movie in the big reveal of what happens
and it reminded me of not being able to
talk again and the whole point of this
movie was you know being a talker being
a slick talker having this be a big part
of who you are and what you do how do
you manage to use your words wisely and
you know a thousand things run through
your mind when you can't talk just like
every other surgeon when I have my ACL
or I broke my right leg or broke my arm
in an accident yeah all these different
things that happen I remember thinking
to myself like one what did I do to
deserve this
of course because you know life's Karma
so at what point did my words impact
somebody else negatively or is this more
of a call from a higher power saying
you're not doing enough with your words
like everything you're doing right now
is so surface what are you doing with
your words that's gonna leave an impact
when you're dead and then what are you
gonna do when you can talk again that's
gonna be different than the man you were
before you lost your voice
because I might not give it back to you
and I had to think about all this stuff
and that's around the time where I was
losing my facial hair and I said Nate so
this guy's like you were on good morning
football at this point I was on good
morning football yeah damn yeah and I
remember coming back like two days too
early and I got on I was trying to tough
it out be an eight again hard head as my
wife always say slide get out of bounce
like don't take the extra hit and I did
it again and I got an ounce for all the
towel and I walked off hour later and I
was like sorry guy that's why things
like now you trippin you came back
anyway but this this all this all kind
of put things in perspective and it's
all it's all like a revolving door of
like you know self realization that you
got to be better even up until this to
this year when Nipsey Hussle past home
there was super impactful in my life
like I loved his music but I loved what
he stood for more being a young
african-american father was an immigrant
and what he did growing up and getting
to hosts curations community of dying in
his community and then this wave of
people around the world that realized
like damn my circumstances or even who I
was or my title when I impact the impact
I have on this life this world and when
he passed selling now at the Staples
Center and so many people like realizing
they had to do more like I came to this
point where I'm like all right Nate if
you die today
mm-hm like nipsey died unfortunately too
soon like what's your legacy now I know
my legacy up to this point it's you know
some you know hundred people thousands
of people will say he's a damn good
player he's tough great teammate man
took a lot of pride in the logo on his
helmet yeah I love that guy man he's a
baller there'd be you know a hundred
kids I say man Nate came and spoke to me
he probably won't remember this but he
he said something to me to change in my
life and maybe like that that tree will
bear fruit and that will help other kids
and then there's gonna be family that
say Nate was never attached to his money
he always said he'll make more and he
gave himself wholeheartedly to everybody
around him and sacrifice a lot but they
not thought like that's good that's for
average person I guess that's it that's
cool but after Nick died I was like it's
not enough man
that's not enough like what am I really
doing here I'm working in New York and
it's cool I'm making money talking
football I got a great job on Sundays
talking football with some legends but
what else am i doing that's gonna make
an impact am i forever gonna be the
football dude I talked about football or
while I create a legacy out of my name
out of my sport that will transcend
anything I ever did on the football
field
like one of my kids gonna think about me
you know what are the youth gonna think
about me like I would love to have an
impact like Nipsey Hussle and people see
me at the casket and say damn that dude
left a mark that will never be a race
like he doesn't even understand the
impact he left so for me like I had this
conversation of my wife I'm like
nipsey's death motivated me mmm I
started reading and I'm not even a heavy
reader like recently on with the Barnes
& Noble and I'm just grabbing books like
my soul is hungry my mind is now what's
really interesting what you're saying is
it's very stoic philosophy so Marcus
Aurelius wrote that what everyone should
do is they should envision their death
and they should envision what you're
saying is one way your impact is to how
are people gonna react but also like are
you gonna be happy if you died it mm-hmm
and it's a really it's an intense thing
it's scary and what I appreciate for the
33% the listeners of this show is that
they're all I talked to all of them in
the DMS and just because you see
somebody doing things that you wish you
could do hmm your mountaintop is their
base camp talk about it and so a lot of
times it's realizing your mortality one
being okay with it like being okay with
the fact that like your life is not
going to live for other yeah ever but
also knowing like if you're doing the
day to day you're going to go somewhere
you don't want to go right that you need
to stop yourself every now and then
whether it's checking in on your mental
health checking in on your physical
health checking in on your the direction
big ships turn slow and you need to look
at that map and every now and then stop
and go am I going in the right direction
because if I'm not this I'm on a boat
and that's a great boat but am I gonna
get to the shore that I really want to
get to and what I appreciate but you
saying it is is you've achieved so much
you're still achieving so much and
everything is great but for everybody
out there that is sitting there going
how the [ __ ] would I even get to that
level right we're all doing it we're all
doing we're all doing it we're all doing
and you should take solace in that fact
you know that that you can take a step
back and you can maybe try meditation
try reading a book yeah try learning
something new yep
your life is not [ __ ] determined yet
yeah it's not not even close
no this [ __ ] is not in [ __ ] ink it is
in pencil not even close
I mean the amount of people that have
achieved there was an actress there's a
mean that was out this actress that was
in Black Panther that didn't pick up
acting until she was 85 and she was in
Black Panthers credits like you you
don't have it's not [ __ ] over guys 2
Chainz got hot in his mid-thirties yes
and he's one of the hottest in the game
like you know it you said it's so
perfectly man it's about kind of like
readjusting what you're doing every so
often to figure out if like the feedback
you're getting is the right type of
feedback because I can get a pat on the
back for being a good football player
forever but at one point it got really
old and crazy it's crazy because it
happened overnight I used to meet people
and if they were a fan
Eagle driven athlete you know being a
Leo big stage talked about me talked
about me I would want people to tell me
how I helped a fantasy are the one game
where I put up three TV shows I mean
yeah I want its feed me put it right
into my vein right but then there was
there was a moment after I got done
playing where I didn't want that I was
feeling for someone to tell me how good
I was on TV I still the same type of
drug though so now what am I looking for
like what void am i filling because
helping guarantor Gonzalez tell me tell
me right and and I was like all right
that's cool like that's cool for me not
to want to be looked as a football
player that shows there's evolution of
mine as far as me and what I'm doing so
I'm doing the right things
now after nips death it's like all right
what's the next evolution like
what do I want somebody to say when they
walk up to me cuz I'm done with you
telling me I'm good I'll buy outright oh
I'll give you a hug and I'll say thanks
I'll sign your honor yeah yeah if you
tell me one good on TV I'll say I
appreciate it man just rying to make
football gonna tell ya but I want I want
something else and and this one is so
much different than the previous before
you telling me how good I was on TV or
as a four-player it was all self-serving
very self-serving at this point I want
somebody to tell me the impact that I
have on what they're doing and then what
they're doing and how that impacts
others and that's that's the Nipsey
Hussle effect i it's really funny you
say that about having this realization
through nipsey i had the realization
last night really
and okay what's Yugi I don't want to get
emotional so when they see us mmm needs
to be watched by everybody yes Ava
Duvernay
did a piece about the Central Park five
about what they went through
yeah the first episode is a [ __ ]
punch in the [ __ ] soul yeah and what
I mean is she edited and shot it in a
way in which it's all happening so fast
that you as a viewer feel as though you
don't have control
just like those five innocent black kids
and how their lives are being taken away
yeah I mean I saw mahomes tweet out man
this first episode is crazy and I texted
him and I was like bro this is [ __ ]
nuts he's like I I couldn't handle it
yeah I me and my fiance watch the last
three episodes yeah and I got done and
for me it was to see how these guys
lives were taken from them yeah for me
to realize if I keep [ __ ] taking this
life for granted talk about it it could
be taken from you so quickly not even
through death right and and also like to
be to like share a lot of myself right
now my fiance is Nigerian I am going to
have interracial children know that they
are going to experience things that I
will never experience inevitable it's
inevitable good in bed and it's it's
there are lessons
I'm not gonna be able to put in part on
them right I'm gonna have to reach out
to people and ask for guidance right how
to share those messages but I felt I
thought about like innocence being taken
from people yeah and I I kind of got
done and and look I want to do I want to
make great things but the same time I
want to have an impact
yeah and it's and it it's it's a scary
thing it's an exciting thing and it
doesn't minimize what we're currently
doing yeah but it also makes me sit back
and go okay what what else can I [ __ ]
do but that listen man for whatever it's
worth I don't need to commend you
because you're just you're just doing
what you need to do as a husband and a
future father husband yet what not has
been yet but you know there's there's so
many people that aren't connected to
just the culture of the judicial system
quite frankly for lack of better words
[ __ ] us over that they turned a blind
eye to it but you're about to be in it
you're about to be entrenched in it and
the more that you can really like arm
yourself with so you can have these
conversations which these real
conversations like you talk about you
know things that will make you emotional
you're gonna talk to your son or your
daughter at eight or nine or ten and
they're gonna have questions for you
that you better have the answer for
right because if you don't you're not
doing your job as a father yeah even me
as an african-american man and standing
for the culture and and always being
proud of Who I am and not afraid to
touch the tough topics like being
inspired and reading books I have all
these books I have self-help in I have
the the the religious books and the
spiritual books and the meditation books
I have the diet books in the Nutri I
have all these books books with purpose
and I thought like okay this is all even
though this is gonna help me at some
point this is still very surface because
as a young black man like how much do I
really know about myself so shout out to
Mike Rob who you know he's one of my
close friends and he works with a phone
network like he is that he is a true
mind of finding out where he's where
he's from and where he's going with
regards to himself and his family and I
bought
100 facts about a Negro just so I can
understand more about where I came from
where my people came from what we have
provided to the world what we have
provided to this country how we came to
scotch all these different things that I
didn't necessarily learn when I was in
elementary or in middle school and you
know why I bought the book because as I
was looking at all these books with
purpose I'm like what's the purpose of
reading books with purpose if I don't
know what my purpose was when I first
got here or my people first got here and
when my son who's 15 turned 16 he's like
hey yo dad you okay I'll talk to you
about something like how much do you
really know about where we come from how
much do you really know about the slave
trade how much do you really know about
the impact of African Americans in their
influence on this country and I and if
I'm stumbling through my words and
trying to Google something while he's
talking to me I didn't do my job as a
parent right so I'm at that point now
where like you said when you see things
that impact you like when they see us of
course it's gonna hit you in the gut
it's the emotional yeah but it prepares
us for life
yes it's preparing you for life it's you
don't get bigger muscles until you tear
them hmm and I think it's important to
realize that good things come from
struggle yeah you know like all the best
things that have happened in my career
have happened right after my biggest
disappointment yeah I was gonna move to
a full-time radio host in Louisville I
didn't get it because I was young didn't
have a family and they gave it to a guy
with a house because they weren't afraid
he was gonna leave Wow right after that
I got a job at oh and and and he had the
job there for like nine months and then
he quit damn
um I was going to get a job in
Philadelphia and I was going to be the
face of Philadelphia sports that was my
plan that's what I've always wanted to
do and I got a phone call and it was hey
sorry we're replacing a woman anchor and
we're told from corporate we have to
hire a woman anchor hmm crushed me got
the job at bleacher report and it's it's
one of those things where yeah it's you
need to like I talked about this my fee
say the reason that I can be a better
man for her is because I failed in some
way and all my relationships in the past
no doubt and this goes to athletics is
the biggest of this no no I mean like no
there are no losses there are only
lessons no doubt and and you don't
Harbor on them you understand that
there's a purpose to that and that that
purpose will drive you forward as a
human and then also in your craft but I
think a lot of people run from hardship
know that when really what you said
about your polyps I think this was the
right thing is why is this happening why
is it happening and you cannot control
people's actions but you can control
your reaction to their actions and
that's what you can have no doubt I knew
this is this is this is what I want it
man yeah it does because we're you know
it's you either run through the motions
or you stop and go why am i running
through the motions yeah I purposely go
home different ways every day yeah
sometimes I get off at 23rd Street
sometimes I get off at 18th Street
sometimes when I get off at 23rd I go
down seven sometimes I go down eighth
because I know I think of that old game
Sims
yeah like gem city we're all just doing
the same [ __ ] every day
and if you don't realize that you have a
path and that you can change that I'm
getting deep you're just gonna go are we
talking about the matrix here oh there's
a huge because there's a huge part of
who we are I do not fault anybody for
being repetitive yeah but it's it we are
we are one big simulation and it's if
you don't adjust your mind adjust your
body adjust your habits then you're
gonna fall into this place of
complacency and then you'll look up five
years ten years from now and you're like
damn what a time go you know that's
that's one thing I think everybody
always says parents say it man I'm
telling you enjoy it now because when
you when they get older it's gonna go by
like that which is true but if you truly
truly invest yourself in the moment it
might not go by that fast like if you
remember everything and for a long time
as a football player quote unquote I was
always going and bringing home the bacon
and I was a football player
so I had to be the star and I'll set the
kicker with my friends and you know I
take the the family on the trip and I
take the wife on the trip but I'm doing
a boy's trip too and it was like I was
always moving and shaking and all these
moments blended and that went by fast
like my NFL career went by really fast
the things I could tell you a handful of
plays but more the locker room which
means I didn't live in the moment too
much and I wish I would have but now
like when I get home I'm so locked into
the family I'm so locked into myself I'm
so locked into Aries is there anything
that you say yourself to snap you out or
do you have anything that you see
yourself in the morning do any tattoos
with certain that remind you of
something like do you have anything that
you that you use as a trigger to be in
the present yeah a quote that I heard
when I was in high school and it's if
better is possible than good isn't
enough so that comes with being a
husband if you're a good husband it's
cool
but if better as possible beau then what
the hell are you doing if you're a good
father
I guess that's cool but you could be a
great one better do it and if you're
good on TV are good on radio or good in
the media space better as possible you
better do it so that's like and if
you're if life is good then you're not
you're not living it to its potential
because it's not about the money for me
like this is how real life got for me
last year there's a 21-day stretch where
I was working I remember talking about
it yeah and I got it in but I was
working for three different networks I
got a check from Fox check from CBS
check mean phone network and I did a
live games the color commentating i did
a CBS of course NFL Network and I
remember going home in January I haven't
told many people this and the wife is
sitting on the couch I said hey you tell
me right now to move back to Arizona I
quit
both of my jobs and I live a regular
life I wake up with you every morning
help me with the kids I detach unplug
you know kind of I have this dream I
joke with her about being on a farm and
and she said well you trip him to relax
I said no no seriously I'm tired I never
do this for the money
we're good like we're fine and we can
cut back on our spending and our
lifestyle we'll be okay
I set up
IRA we're good they did the the ladders
of income are coming in babe we're good
and she said no I think I said I'm not
tripping I called the family little Nate
Nehemiah Mia come here they're
everywhere in the house I said sit down
what what that I go down I'm Mia do you
want to move back to Arizona if you guys
all the side of the family way I'm
quitting my job I don't know if I can do
this anymore and she said well you know
we got a pool here and we got I really
like pool she's on the fence Nehemiah's
I you know Arizona was nice man sunny
and I did like my school that I was that
I wouldn't mind it Nate who is the he's
a lot like me he never likes to shake
things up he's mister go at the flow I
thought for sure I would have bet
everything on it he would have said yeah
dad I don't like it out it because he's
made some comments over the last few
years where because he's very passive
that it may be like New Jersey New York
it sometimes could be overwhelming sure
so I thought for sure that he's gonna be
the one that tipped the scale and I was
gonna listen to him cuz he never says
anything yeah and he pauses for a second
he shrugged his shoulders and he's kind
of slouching and see this he's 14 at the
time you know and I'm trying to teach
him to be a minute
I said sit up talk with some bass in
your voice look mean your look me in my
eyes and tell me what's on your mind
yeah cuz I don't want you to say I never
listened to you he set up looking in my
eyes he said dad I'm going in high
school next year I have a group of
friends here I get here I'm tired of
moving mmm yeah immediately this weight
lifted off my shoulders and the whole
family went that's what we do that's
what we're doing he said that's what
we're doing I said I'll have the same
you know we said like adjusting your
sales I said we'll have the same
conversation next year and maybe next
year is not due to stress it's just due
to me figuring out if this is what I
really want and I said we're here we're
staying and that day like I went from
like being exhausted like oh man let me
sleep for two weeks to just like I what
are we doing tonight and like my family
resent me in that moment man and it's
it's like she can get real man yeah it
can get heavy so yours is a farm in
Arizona it's no my wife's from Arizona
Oh
but it's it's a farm my wife wants to
live on water deep in the future sure
we're trying to find a place we can get
a farm on water I think it's Hawaii but
I want to be on a farm and I'm not any
type of yeah agricultural do ya but the
idea of having spotty service and a few
channels and technology not ruining your
world like an episode of Black Mirror
yeah like that intrigues me my give it
all away is I check around my fiancee
all the time let's just move to Anguilla
and be bartenders and just like be on an
island thanks great does we have enough
money that with the way it is down there
we'd be able to just live and we didn't
life be good we'll just bartend and well
it will handle tourists then hang out
the live sets of clothes like yeah just
go to the beach every day
that in that that sounds great it sounds
great sounds great but then people are
gonna listen to this and go Nate and
left go already have two jobs that I
wish that I could have and I don't think
that either of us take it for granted
which is why we're in a position where
we work our ass off to provide the best
form of entertainment to the people that
are listening and watching us yeah that
felt good may I appreciate you coming in
making time in your schedule that's
insane you've been up since 4:00 a.m.
today I hope that the 33% has enjoyed it
and with this okay I'm going to send it
off real quick hey I can do this [ __ ]
and my rhymes always stick a le FK o 2e
hanging out at the na TTE hey I can make
the flow go so you know if you want to
go I could go with it Sonny what it's no
I can catch a pass from cost of wins and
I can do the [ __ ] again and again and he
look real deep and find me Jack he could
go to Sproles cuz he's playing in the
back hey it hurts across the mill house
on Jeffrey's never playing that a second
fiddle I could do a little rain did a
little and make it feel so good and I
got a center low cut my Eric will hey I
see what you did there see that was ill
that Philly flow something like Meek
Mill these his bars off the top of the
dome I'm chilling in about 45 minutes
I'll be home but [ __ ] I'm grown
yeah it got kind of heavy everybody
talking but they not ready see we
putting work from the a.m. to the p.m.
and chill girls don't slide in not Dean
hey cuz we love we got the ladies and I
know y'all guess I mean y'all women
shady but are the queens we shown you
love me and left Co all of the above
ah 33 percent y'all the [ __ ] hit up Nate
Burleson on social tell them how much
you appreciate him being on here to all
the homies holla holla holla holla at
you later facts
[Music]